hey Vsauce Michael here and here I am
the real Michael this Michael was
created by a brilliant young man named
Mitchell who brought it to me at a
meet-and-greet after brain candy live it
is phenomenal and obviously the most
handsome jack-in-the-box ever Everest is
a mountain that's eight point eight four
eight kilometers tall its size is
impressive or is it
let's cut earth the entire planet write
an app straight through Everest and then
start zooming out as you can see
Everest SMAW new mentality quickly
disappears against Earth's planetary
ginormous 'ti compared to Earth's
diameter Everest in fact all of Earth's
ruggedness barely registers now that can
seem surprising since we're often
surrounded by diagrams and maps and
globes that exaggerate Earth's
topography now there's a good reason to
do that but it leads to a misconception
about just how smooth earth is here's a
typical example a cross-section of the
United States that I found on reddit the
vertical axis spans about 10,000 feet
but the horizontal axis represents
nearly 14 million stretched to the same
scale so as to mirror reality the actual
smoothness of the earth becomes apparent
on this one foot diameter globe Everest
is a bump about two millimeters high
feels good but if the earth was actually
this small Everest would be a bump only
1/5 of a millimeter high it's 10 times
taller than it should be
only 24 people have seen the earth with
their own eyes as a circle small enough
to be looked right at not as the whole
world but as a little thing suspended
alone in space the further away you are
from a ball the more of its surface you
can see now we don't always notice this
because in our day-to-day lives most of
the balls we deal with are so small
they're almost always many of their own
radii away from us and the available
amount of their surface visible as near
a maximum or they're so big
like the earth that we rarely get far
enough away fast enough to notice this
property but the next time you are near
a ball get close to it you'll see that
as you get nearer more of its surface
disappears behind the horizon but moving
back up will make it available again for
most of us stuck our whole lives on
Earth's surface such an experience is
impossible with nothing around to block
your review 5 kilometers about 3 miles
is about the furthest you can see now
haze can limit your view an atmospheric
refraction can slightly extend it but
for the most part everything you can see
happens within an area of just 80 square
kilometers that's not bad but it's tiny
compared with what there is to see the
higher up you go of course the further
away you'll be able to see that's why
it's great to be a satellite here's the
International Space Station yeah look at
that nice big portion of the surface in
view unfortunately this isn't to scale
if the earth were the size of an apple
how far away with the International
Space Station orbit like this far away
maybe this far away maybe this far away
actually it orbits here 2.7 millimeters
above the service that's how far the
stem of this Apple sticks up that's not
very far oh here's another fun little to
scale fact if the earth were the size of
an apple your eyeball would be about the
size of the moon
we often imagine that from the
International Space Station astronauts
see the earth like this but they're just
not that far away from where they
actually orbit International Space
Station residents only see about three
percent of Earth's surface at any one
time and that three percent is too wide
to all fit within a window when I was in
Pittsburgh their science museum had a
mock-up of part of the ISS and as you
can see out of the window
earth is still quite expansive using
special lenses images can be taken from
the ISS that look like circular discs
Earth's but the lenses distorting things
here it's fitting much more into the
picture in order to truly witness
Earth's entire shape with your own eyes
you would need to either smash your face
right up against a window or just be
floating outside the station and even
then you would have to move your head to
see from edge to edge so how high up do
you have to go to see the edges of Earth
all at once and even if you did that how
much would you actually see how much is
there to see earth is made of stuff lots
of stuff water and dirt and rocks and
air all of which are composed of atoms
tiny things so teeny that a single drop
of water contains not a million atoms
not a billion atoms or a trillion or a
quadrillion or a quintillion but five
sextillion atoms earth is made of even
more stuff not a septal Ian Adams not an
octal Ian non-alien Dessel Ian
undecillion duo de silient Redis iliyan
not even a Quattro de Cillian but 100
Quin de Cillian atoms but since we live
only on the surface of our planet we
unfortunately can't see most of those
atoms if the earth was shaped like a
disk or an icosahedron or say a cube or
a rectangular prism or
who stellated rhombic dodecahedron we
could see more of the earth than we
normally can but as things are we
actually see nearly the least of Earth's
matter possible because of all solids a
sphere which the earth approximately is
has the smallest surface area to volume
ratio the most stuff inside and the
least stuff outside so how many of these
ten to the fifty atoms that make up
earth are on the surface for us to see
that's not an easy question for one
thing
technically atoms on the surfaces of
opaque things like rocks and dirt aren't
the only parts involved in their
appearances subsurface scattering can
and does happen regardless attempting
even a rough approximation is
illuminating
I asked grant from the YouTube channel
three blue one Brown for some help and
he pointed out that if you calculate the
number of circles with atom-sized radii
that could packed optimally cover a
sphere with the surface area of Earth
you get about 1.5 times ten to the 34th
that's a lot of atoms but then he
pointed out that the Earth's surface
isn't smooth its roughness provides
extra surface area for atoms to occupy
without a complete description of the
shape of Earth's surface every mountain
and valley every bump on every rock this
is just gonna be hopeless right well
here's the thing
earth is made of little rugged shapes
that from far away make big rugged
shapes in other words Earth's surface
can be described as a fractal there's a
regularity to its roughness in fact
mathematicians have even assigned a
fractal dimension to Earth's surface 2.3
now to see what that means I highly
recommend grants video on fractal
dimensions
it's fascinating using two point three
and assuming that it applies from the
scale of a human hair up to that of a
mountain grant found that the number of
atoms on Earth's surface changes
significantly up from a power of 34 to a
power of 37 that's a thousand times more
atoms so maybe we shouldn't count
Earth's roughness out just yet
it's smooth but not perfectly to put
that number in perspective the human
body contains about 10 to the 27 atoms
that's 10 powers of 10 less than the
surface of the earth 10 powers of 10 is
10 billion there are about seven and a
half billion humans so more or less it
can be said that there are the same
number of atoms in every human body
right now as there are on the surface of
the earth as I've shown before all human
bodies piled into one place would barely
even fill the Grand Canyon but all human
atoms spread across the earth would
almost perfectly cover it just one atom
deep but back the mass of the atmosphere
is about 2.5 percent less than what you
would get by multiplying sea level
pressure 14.7 pounds per square inch by
the surface area of the earth because
Earth's terrain displaces about that
much air Earth's surface is pretty cool
obviously I mean it's got lichen and
monster trucks and an island in a lake
on an island in a lake on an island but
from down here on its surface we just
can't see that much of it your view of
Earth is obstructed by lots of opaque
things walls buildings trees rocks
terrain if earth was flat you could see
further
but sorry it's a rough world out there
or is it if you could hold the earth in
your hands like this how bumpy would it
actually feel we already saw that even
our planets biggest bumps barely
register relative to Earth's size but
let's go somewhere famously flat where
relative to our size terrain rarely gets
in the way of seeing lots of the planet
the US state of Kansas I grew up here
and took this footage while driving
across the state last year you can
probably see why Kansas is often called
flatter than a pancake however although
it is famously flat Kansas is not the
flattest u.s. state in a fantastic piece
of research
Jerome Dobson and Joshua Campbell
defined looks flat like this if from a
given point any part of the terrain
within the horizon Rises more than 0.32
degrees up about the height of a 30
meter hill at the horizon a typical
person would say well hey that part's
not flat by cleverly applying this rule
to topographical data they were able to
give every state a flatness score West
Virginia was the least flat Kansa was
only the seventh flattest Delaware
Minnesota Louisiana North Dakota and
Illinois are all by this method flatter
than Kansas as was the number one
flattest state Florida
Adam Savage and I had the pleasure of
visiting Florida with our brain candy
live show this year and as this footage
from atop the King Center in Melbourne
Florida shows it's pretty gosh dang flat
now even though Kansas is not the
flattest it is the state most often
ranked flattest when the general
population is asked it is
truly scientifically flatter than a
pancake it's been demonstrated but
there's more to the story than that
in 2003 researchers took a 130
millimeter wide pancake procured from
IHOP and analyzed its local release they
found the difference between high and
low points was on the order of about two
millimeters if a typical pancake like
this was the size of Kansas five million
times larger two millimeter high Peaks
would be ten kilometer high mountains in
comparison Mount Everest is only about
eight point eight kilometers tall and
Earth's deepest scar the Marianas Trench
is thought to be just under 11
kilometers deep so not only is Kansas
about as smooth as a pancake but so is
every other state in the Union and so is
the entire world if you were a giant
holding the planet in your hands like
this you and it would be torn apart by
the immense tidal forces created by your
gravities if somehow you could avoid
that though the planet would feel not
much rougher than running your hands
over a pancake but a soggy one right I
mean most of Earth's surface is covered
in water your hands would get wet
or would they yes earth is covered in
liquid but the depth of that liquid like
the mountains above just doesn't compare
to the total size of the planet as it
turns out if the earth was the size of a
typical classroom globe like this one
one foot in diameter the volume of water
contained in above and on it would only
be about 14 milliliters
that's this much water it's kind of hard
to believe because at this scale
spreading this much water across all of
the oceans surfaces would be pretty much
impossible due to surface tension but
this is it all of Earth's water compared
to all of Earth 90% of the space on our
planet life can live in is in here the
other 10% is dry land so no you wouldn't
get wrinkly fingers playing with an
earth like this you could stop it dry
just with a paper towel despite the
incredible area oceans cover on our
planet their depth is just nothing
compared to the size of our entire
planet
now you may have heard it said that if
the entire planet were shrunk down to
the size of a billiard ball it would be
smoother than a billiard ball after all
we've seen so far that seems believable
but as it turns out it's not true the
misconception stems from the
interpretation of the world pool
billiard Association's rules now
according to them a ball must have a
diameter of 2.25 inches plus or minus 5
thousandths of an inch
now some writers have taken this to mean
that pits and bumps of five thousandths
of an inch are allowed proportionately
on earth that would mean a mountain that
was 28 kilometers high so since Earth
has none of those earth must be smoother
than a billiard ball except if bumps
that high were actually allowed on a
pool ball a ball covered with 120 grit
sandpaper would be within regulation
clearly the 5,000th rule is more about
roundness deviation from a sphere and
not texture in fact as microscopic
photography has shown imperfections on
regulation balls are only 1/100
thousandth of an inch or about half a
micrometer deep and high scale down to
the size of a billiard ball Earth's
Marianas Trench would be 49 micrometer
is deep so earth is smoother than a
pancake but not smoother than a billiard
ball nor as xkcd wonderfully showed is
earth smoother than a bowling ball but
hold on
earlier we were using the word flat now
we're using the word smooth that
distinction is important you see the
earth isn't flat like a plane instead it
curves it's a ball pieces of Earth like
Kansas might be quite smooth but they
curve along with earth if you were to
stand in the middle of Kansas people on
the eastern or western edges of the
state would appear to be not level with
you but about 8.1 kilometers below you
that's nearly the height of Everest and
if they stood straight up they'd be
tilted nearly two degrees relative to
where you thought up was now here's an
interesting coincidence generally
speaking one mile from where you are
earth curves down about eight inches one
kilometer from where you stand it curves
down about eight centimeters now the
rate of drop due to curvature isn't a
linear one you can't just multiply any
distance by eight to get the drop due to
curvature instead use an online
calculator like the one I've linked down
in this video's description you can put
in any distance you want anyway the
visibility limit caused by Earth's
curvature is your horizon it encircles
you like a visual cage but it's a cage
whose radius is determined by how high
up your eyes are Conan O'Brien at six
foot four inches tall can see up to five
kilometers in any direction but Snooky
at four foot eight can only see about
four point three to find out how far
away your horizon is geometrically just
use the online tools I've put down in
the description below Earth's texture
can get in the way of your horizon but
can also cause things beyond the horizon
to peek into view hey what's that com
factors all of this in now if earth was
a smooth sphere the view from atop been
nevus the highest mountain in the
British Isles would end at the horizon
131 km/h with look like this but
factoring in Earth's ups and downs
here's a more precise boundary of what
you can see locked rate Scottish Gaelic
for Lake of death is only about 10 miles
from the peak that's within an 80 mile
radius but it can't be seen because
terrain in the way blocks it parts of
the Atlantic Ocean and the North Sea
eight times further away can be seen
they lie at the limit of Earth's
curvature just before it bends the
surface out of sight
these spikes extending beyond the
geometric horizon are caused by things
beyond it that are tall enough to peak
above Earth's curvature in the case of
ben nevis this includes high elevation
parts of Northern Ireland okay enough
about the surface and what it's like
close up let's go further away and see
more this will be fun but there will be
a trade-off the further away you are
from something the smaller it will
appear to be moving away from Earth will
make more area available to see but that
area will take up less of your field of
view it can be difficult to illustrate
this in a YouTube video because your
field of view the shape and size of what
you can see with your head still just by
moving your eyes around is about a
hundred and twenty degrees up and down
and more than a hundred and eighty
degrees horizontal a screen is just a
window of that space nowhere close to
filling it unless you get uncomfortably
close to help us visualize large
apparent sizes let's replace the
spherical earth with a flat disk that's
always the same distance from the
observer this disk can be given an
apparent size equal to Earth's from any
altitude and the disk can contain on it
everything that would fit within your
horizons from any altitude ok so
standing on the surface looking straight
down Earth will take up nearly a fall
180 degrees of your field of view with
your arms extended straight out parallel
to earth your fingers will point to the
edges of the planet your horizon from
400 kilometers up about where the ISS
orbits 3% of the earth's surface is
within your horizon but the earth will
only take up about a hundred and forty
degrees of your vision your fingers
would point to Earth's edges if you
narrowed your arms angles each by the
width of two outstretched fists one fist
is about ten degrees across at arm's
length now you can move your eyes from
edge to edge horizontally here but you
can't quite take in the full width
vertically but for more than twice this
altitude
1,000 kilometers away earth is only a
hundred and twenty degrees across that's
one less fist-width
each mrs. perfect that fits within our
narrower vertical field of view so from
a thousand kilometers up about six
hundred and twenty miles you can just
start to see earth as a complete disc
right in front of you at once
however only 7% of Earth fits within the
horizon from up here images of Earth
taken by satellites this far up like the
suomi npp look kind of weird
I mean North America doesn't actually
take up this much of the globe Earth's
120 degree width has been compressed to
fit in an image much narrower compared
Africa from its height to the famous
blue marble picture taken from 45,000
kilometers away
the latter looks more realistic like
looking at a globe on your desk
geosynchronous satellites are about
thirty five thousand kilometres high
from their altitude 43.4% nearly a whole
half of Earth's surface is visible but
the earth only takes up a meager 17
degrees you could completely cover it
with two outstretched palms that's
incredible but what about from the moon
well from that far away earth is only
about two degrees across you could block
it out with your outstretched thumb
however you can see more of Earth you
can see further around its curvature
from the moon 49% of Earth's surface is
visible just 49 if you want to see 50
half of Earth's surface at once you have
to go even further away in fact you have
to go infinitely far away
which you can't the most of a sphere you
can see at once with your own eyes is
just half but in the real world way
before you were actually infinitely far
away the amount of light reaching you
from Earth's surface would become so
small and infrequent that you wouldn't
be able to see anything at all
stars like our Sun are much brighter and
bigger than the earth but only a handful
have even with our best technology been
resolved as anything larger than just a
single point from one thousandth of a
light year away our own Sun would look
like every other star in the sky a
single point to the naked eye only about
as wide as our Doradus the widest star
in our sky from 91 light-years away the
point of our Sun would dim to a level
undetectable by the naked eye it would
disappear most of the stars in the night
sky you can see with your naked eye are
further away than that we can see them
though because they're brighter and
bigger than our own Sun which means if
there's life out there living in systems
around the Stars we've marveled at and
written stories about since humanity
began chances are we are not part of
their constellations or folklore we're a
dark patch in the sky to them and ignore
ball emptiness framing other stars the
ones they marvel at while not knowing
we're here or that there's anything here
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
if you don't follow me on Twitter or
Instagram you are missing out on a
treasure trove of premium content so
check that out and know this I love you
oh and this Vsauce shirt is only
available to curiosity box subscribers
this shirt comes in the latest box if
you sign up now you will get this shirt
so long as you sign up before it sells
out
the curiosity box is good for all brains
it comes to your door four times a year
full of science gear and toys that I
want you to have I want you to hold and
learn from also a portion of the
proceeds from every box goes to
Alzheimer's research I'm incredibly
proud of it but what's going on on this
shirt well it's modular multiplication
around a circle we have the numbers 1 to
40 around the outside of a circle
connected to their product with the
number 4 so one is connected to 4 2 is
connected to 8 3 is connected to 12 and
so on even past 40 you could keep
imagining the numbers continuing for
instance one can become 40 1 2 can
become 42 and this emerges the Vsauce be
many other shapes can be made by using
different multipliers or different
numbers around the circle math a logger
has a fantastic video on this topic
which you should check out if linked it
down in the description thank you for
being curious and as always thanks for
watching